and this was especially important to me
because
actresses and the culture around
actresses and worshiping actresses is
such a real part of my life with my gay
friends here in LA and we don't we
actually play the classic celebrity
celebrity and salad bowls some know it
um and this is a really tough calculator
like the calculus of deciding which two
actresses would be referenced here was a
lot went into it
oh my God all of those uh guesses from
from will are Conrad ad-libs kind of had
its own guesses one of the most my
favorite days to shoot I I barely do
anything uh in this scene but it was
just so fun to sit back and watch Matt
and Tomas do this over and over and over
and over again remember Alicia Ander I
mean she was really great in ex machina
you need to stay out of
here
we're sending Matt and Tomas you know
the the clips to my cousin Vinnie and
they're like we're familiar
[Music]